qu'est ce que moi j'ai un coup de gueule
depuis hier parce que j'ai un coup
d'oeil sur nafissatou diallo parce qu'on
est en train d'assister à une affaire
qui est en train de devenir la sphère
paris match pour rappel elle avait signé
des clauses de confidentialité elle
devait pas parler puis là ça commence à
s'étaler on a découvert encore
aujourd'hui dans paris match on en
découvre tous les jours donc c'est en
train de devenir une vraie affaire est
effectif et moi ça me dérange beaucoup
voilà donc je sais pas si vous avez des
images alors on a désigné mois alors on
en a pas d'image s'éprend qu'un piéton
alors soutenons le coup de gueule ton
coup de gueule raymond c'est il ya d une
décision elle a décidé à la halle évoqué
sa décision de parler dans paris match
elle a dit cette histoire va monsieur
jusqu'à la fin de mes jours il m'est
impossible de rester silencieuse j'ai
donc décidé de donner ma vérité j'ai
énormément souffert et entendu beaucoup
d'horreurs sur moi c'est pour ça qu'elle
a dit toi tu ne décolère pas sur sept
mois je ne décolère pas et liart j'ai
été mal compris par certaines personnes
pourquoi je ne décolère pas parce que
moi je pense que ça ne s'achète pas ça
s'achète pas la justice que ce soit les
les gars qui font des agressions
sexuelles les pédophiles et cetera et
cetera elle avait les clés en main elle
avait les clés en main pour que ce
procès il existe elle pouvait emmener
dominique strauss kahn devant la justice
elle pouvait l'emmener pour 20 ans de
placard quand les mecs qui commencent à
proposer un million cinq cent mille
dollars
c'est mon point de vue c'est que t'as
pas les fesses propres ce qui peut
t'arriver des choses c'est à la mifa la
justice et non à bas alors elle a livré
sa propre version des faits je vous le
dis témoignage d'un complet qui
s'explique par le contrat de
confidentialité qu'elle a signé avec dsk
alors elle explique je m'apprête à
entrer dans la chambre sur la gauche
quand je vois apparaître cet homme nu
alors je m'écris oh mon dieu je suis
désolé puis tout est arrivé
et quand cela était fini je ne suis
enfui en trash en partout je me cache
dans le couloir près de la chambre 28 20
et de là je vois cet homme sortir
habillé tirant une valise derrière lui
nos regards se croisent il disparaît
dans l'ascenseur oui jurado mais raymond
en fait on voit ce que j'arrive pas à
comprendre ce que tu dis mais je
comprends ton point de vue mais tu ne
connais pas enfin tu ne connais pas
l'état dans lequel était nafissatou
diallo au moment où elle a signé ce
contrat
tu sais pas comment il était est ce
qu'elle était sous emprise est-ce
qu'elle avait peur est ce qu'elle était
sous influence ses avocats par exemple
lui ont conseillé n de poursuivre les
jusqu'à procédure et elle ne voulait pas
parce qu'elle avait peur parce qu'elle a
perdu son boulot suite à ça elle a perdu
son boulot de
deux chambres elle avait plus de
couverture sociale elle a dû dès
scolariser son enfant le mettre dans une
école privée et donc la halle était en
panique
toute l'histoire toute l'histoire et
j'entends ce que tu me lis et je suis
touché par ça et je suis pas en train de
cautionner le fait que les est ce que
les gens qui font des agressions
sexuelles c'est bien fait pas ça que je
cautionne je dis juste que ça fait du
tort à plein d'autres femmes plein
d'autres femmes qui vont se dire la
justice est pourrie ça sert à rien
d'aller déposer plainte
il ya eu 58 me la lente mais là il ya eu
58 mille plaintes en 2010 mais plus que
2010 est au contraire vraiment vraiment
pas ce qu'on peut me laisser tout si on
place qu'on peut laisser réagir
il a eu bien sûr à charge l'impression
là dessus non mais je suis pas trop trop
d'accord parce que je parle du point de
vue qlailé les femmes qui y vivent
l'agression que je n'assistais tous que
nafissatou diallo a vécu ont beaucoup de
pression en fait pour aller porter
plainte et je comprends pas pourquoi vu
que son affaire a été plus médiatisés
que les autres elle devrait d'un seul
coup devenir une sorte de d'héroïne et
et va déjà il faut que les ailes en est
une en survivant à son agression est ce
qu'elle est en train de faire c'est ce
cas c'est ce qu'elle veut devenir aveu
devine devenir une héroïne pour faire un
livre pour ouvrir des centres pour les
femmes mais ça c'est très bien et moi je
dis je remets pas en cause son histoire
et la sordidité de l'histoire je remets
juste en cause
moi ce qui me dérange c'est d'acheter la
justice c'est de se dire mais si parce
que quand tu ne m'entendras toutes les
cartes en main il est connu il ya des
grands avocats qui sent mais la belle a
toutes les cartes en main pour le faire
plonger 20 piges
là on parle pas là après l'accident elle
a dit je suis hors de moi j'ai peur je
ne sais pas quoi faire je pense que je
veux aller chercher quelque chose dans
la chambre 28 20 il me reste encore
beaucoup de choses à faire et elle dit
cet homme dsk avait de l'argent et du
pouvoir
je voulais assure que s'il avait été
pauvre à la rue un clochard il serait
aujourd'hui en prison oui gilles verdez
deux choses vraiment c'est pas elle qui
a arrêté l'action au pénal c'est le
procureur qui a prouvé qu'elle était
affaiblie par une série de mensonges
qu'a dit je ne peux pas aller là bas ils
sont élus je ne peux pas aller au procès
je vais perdre elle elle voulait aller
au procès et à propos de l'accord est un
juriste qui m'a dit aujourd'hui que
quand vous signé une clause de
confidentialité ou il ya un français
donc il y avait des sk vous êtes obligé
de mettre une durée parce que sinon
c'est à durée indéterminée et c'est
comme un contrat de travail vous pouvez
les cas c'est en attaquant donc ils ont
mais une durée et on m'a dit que sans
doute si elle parle aujourd'hui des
claques dû hériter de 800 immigrants le
droit de parler justement alors et ils
sont venus aussi sur la justice new
yorkaise et le procureur avait soulevé
le manque de crédibilité de nafissatou
diallo
et souvenez vous ces images de
vidéosurveillance et avait tout remis en
cause ça ça a pesé dans près de 6 à tous
diallo est assise elle n'est ni prostré
ni ampleur huit minutes d'attentes avant
que l'un des agents écoute son
témoignage après le coup de fil à la
police les deux agents de l'hôtel derek
mai et brian lee routes vont s'isoler
on les retrouve dans un autre local où
ils sont seuls sans témoin ils se
parlent puis soudainement explose de
joie
il se frappe dans les mains et
s'enlacent derek mais réalise quelques
pas de danse
voilà alors ça ça n'a pas joué pour elle
oui ce que mes parents si on leur
reproche de ne pas être effondré ne pas
pleurer
elle est victime et en plus on leur
reproche de ne pas en faire assez on
peut qu'on est traumatisé on est un état
de sidération
on sait même pas comment réagir et
caetera et les femmes violées qui ne
portent pas parce qu'elles sont
complètement elle n'arrive pas dire
moins de même à leurs agresseurs et
c'est parce que son état de sidération
et là on lui reproche de pas pleurer
parce que sinon si la halle c'est
logique que les femmes aient peur
aujourd'hui de porter plainte parce que
justement comme ça en train de se passer
là actuellement on les remet tout le
temps comme ça on remet tout en cause et
des victimes et ça c'est pas normal
alors penser que les mecs qui sont pas
jugés parce qu'ils sortent le
portefeuille
que ça les aide ça les femmes ça les
aide ça nécessite quand ils ont des
problèmes de santé et tous ils sortent
de prison en france c'est la même chose
la justice elle est pareil haution 58
mille plaintes en 2019 sur les violences
les fans alors tu parles avec des femmes
qui sont approchés à te dise j'y vais
pas parce que ça va servir à rien et je
préfère regarder passer cette odyssée
500 à la ferraille
elle a dit que sa vie a totalement
basculé ce jour là tout a changé
maj oisifs s'est envolé définitivement
se souvenir ne me quittera jamais ce qui
s'est passé a été dévastateur pour moi
elle a dit qu'elle avait été menacée de
mort aussi un j'ai dû quitter mon
appartement emménager dans un immeuble
sécurisé en dehors de new york une nuits
en rentrant dans mon restaurant de mon
restaurant à 2h30 du matin j'ai été
suivi par 1 4 4 du groupe jusqu'au
connecticut où j'habitais pourquoi elle
était menacée de mort parce que on lui a
reproché des mensonges elle a été suivie
elle a même embauché de nouveaux avocats
pour attaquer en diffamation tous les
gens qui mettrait en cause son
témoignage
notamment il ya eu dans l' affaire dsk
son témoignage sur un viol en guinée
qu'elle aurait subis elle vient de
guinée
l'accord et le procureur n'a pas trouvé
la preuve de ce viol il a remis en
question son témoignage et il s'est dit
peut-être que c'est la même chose pour
dsk je suis pas du côté du tout de dsk
affaiblit pas son témoignage
mais il y avait des failles dans ce
qu'elle disait et pour appeler c'est
effectivement ce que disait gilles c'est
que aux états unis c'est pas comme en
france les procureurs sont élus
donc ils ne vont au procès que
lorsqu'ils sont quasiment sûrs à 99,9
pour cent de gagner parce qu'ils veulent
être réélus et le procureur en question
à l'époque il est toujours le jour du
joueur aujourd'hui toujours en poste
donc lui il a tout fait pour garder son
poste voilà en tout cas c'est une
interview exclusive à que par nature et
raymond le fait ça ne choque le fait
d'accepter de l'argent que tu es au
procès la très grande majorité des
processus panis terminent par un
arrangement financier
voilà c'est comme ça ça s'était enivré
regardons ce système là où on peut
aujourd'hui aux etats-unis peut-être en
france même gardons ce système où on
peut acheter des pertes et pas d'armé
je m'intéresse c'est le vrai combat qui
m'intéresse c'est que les femmes avaient
le courage de parler tout de suite comme
on le dit qu'elle rentre qu'elles
rentrent pas chez elle avant l'événement
qu'elle ait tout de suite on gendarmerie
c'est très dur je sais que c'est très
dur je suppose je suis mal placé pour
savoir parce que je suis ni femmes et ni
violé mais c'est très dur à faire mais
il faut que ces femmes aient le courage
là il est là le vrai combat un dollars
de dommages-intérêts 20 ans de taule
c'est ça qui doit se passer ce que tu
fais pas qu'on achète pas vraiment qui
peu d'internautes oui je sais ça
m'horripile
le wydad or elle aime pas quand il est
originaire mais on ne peut pas dire que
les femmes qui ne portent pas plainte
tout de suite ne sont pas courage et pas
des gars 7 à 3 à 10 ans il ya dix ans 2
2 places à plessala dix ans de même si
elles pantois nantes 10 m ont laissé
parler les jambes même si elle valérie
dix ans après elle est courageuse mais
je dis pas qu'elle est alors allé ce que
vous compte c'est que je n'ai pas dit ça
valéry jusqu'au penser que dominique
strauss kahn va répondre
hanafi c'est en soutenant et j'espère
que non non non non non c'est changer
d'accord c'est sur certains avocats
disent que comme elle a cassé peut-être
l'accord eh bien il pourrait
éventuellement si elles m'ont demandé la
la le rendu de ses 1 million de dollars
oui en réalité n'a pas casser l'accord
c'est pour ça qu'elle a utilisé des mots
extrêmement choisi bien sûr elle a parlé
d'accident et non pas de viol donc
effectivement parce que ça a été dénoncé
comme ce n'était pas un viol donc il est
vrai quant à cette histoire elle est
juste la justice américaine qui fait ça
en france on peut pas faire ça tu peux
pas acheter les yeux les jugent encore
appelons en charge aime le dire s'est
fait violer qui a dit ce violent qui a
disparue dans l'annoncé bien qu'elle est
en train de faire une manoeuvre pour
faire un livre pour refaire des alors
celle là elle a parlé de ses projets
futurs juste devant semaines a dit
qu'elle l'homme d'église
il ya un homme d'église qui l'aident à
écrire son livre en plus de cet ouvrage
la jeune femme compte lancer une
fondation dans le but d'aider des femmes
en détresse comme vous l'a dit hier et
c'est là que ça vous dérange
non si elle le fait ça me dérange pas du
tout si elle le fait c'est très bien qui
c'est qui peut être contre ce projet la
personne mais moi dans mon cas dans mon
fonds à moi je sais ça me dérange de
dire qu'on te donne un million va t'en
étais toi
d'accord je me tais ça me dérange pas je
deviens sert pas la fête pourquoi les
entendre une cause voire une coque est
si grave ont créé cette formation elle a
attendu quinze neuf ans pour créer cette
fondation pour venir en aide aux femmes
qui comme elle arrive de l'échangé mais
ça ceux qui ont du mal qui parlent pas
la langue qui n'ont pas les papiers que
c'était elle veut les aider
c'est une très belle action mais
pourquoi elle a attendu
ça qui dérange être parce qu'elle a eu
l'argent elle a eu l'argent elle a
ouvert un restaurant s'est planté à
l'aube au walhalla echirey ce qui lui
reste encore de le faire
non non je dis non c'est pour ça que il
ya eu le restaurant qui a brûlé il ya eu
le projet vaseux en guinée il ya eu le
pseudo achat d'un immobile à trois
étages à dakar dont on n'a jamais
retrouvé trace et c'est peut-être cette
arnaque et donc elle n'a plus d'argent
three merci pour ça qu'elle veut un
livre qui va apporter énormément d'amis
savoir qu aux etats unis cette affaire
n'intéresse plus personne à bord des
deux sauts lui ment aux états unis chez
nous
la presse américaine s'en fichent merci
à les tribunes où il ya doute est la
pureté des intentions effectivement de
nafissatou égard aux restaurants aux
millions effectivement aux différentes
entreprises qui n'étaient pas pour les
autres femmes et qui était pour elle ce
qu'on peut comprendre mais du coup on
peut aussi comprendre qu'on doute de la
pureté de ses intentions je pense que
c'est ce que veut dire raymond alors on
aura un concert souvent